today we are talking about my first
paper your first academic paper yeah not
precisely the first one not the first
one I ever had my name on uh but the
first one that I had my name first on
which meant it was mine so name first
does matter does it it does yeah
different disciplines have different
conventions but in astronomy the first
author is the person who sort of takes
responsibility for the paper and also
gets a little bit more of the credit so
in this case this was the first paper
that came out of my PhD so it was
important that this was my intellectual
work because it was part of the training
that I was doing to get my PhD it is
infrared observations of gravitational
lensing in Abel 2219 with Cersei and I
wouldn't have been able to tell you that
without reading it's been a while it was
published in the monthly notices of the
Royal Astronomical Society which is
where I publish most of my papers even
now it's the professional body for
astronomers in the UK but it's read and
people publish in it from around the
world so I was newly arrived in the UK
I'd come from Canada I was experiencing
an awful lot of culture shock an awful
lot of imposter syndrome because I was
at Cambridge surrounded by absolutely
brilliant individuals but I was also
really excited because I had come to do
a PhD in astronomy at one of the best
places in the world and I was getting to
work on a topic that I was really
interested in and that was gravitational
lensing and the idea was that we were
going to use this brand new instrument
with new capabilities it hadn't been
used before to do something in a way
that people hadn't been able to do
before and that was equal parts exciting
and anxiety inducing and nerve-wracking
because it involved new instrumentation
and that carried with it some risk and
when you're on a short PhD and I had
three years of funding at the time that
risk May things a little bit
nerve-wracking everything was riding on
one trip to La Palma in the Canary
Islands four nights in June to get this
camera working gather the data and then
bring it back and actually get some
results from it and which telescope did
you get time on it was the William
Herschel telescope and it has a 4.2
meter diameter primary mirror at the
time it was sort of a medium to Big
telescope now it's a medium to small
telescope as we've built bigger and
bigger facilities but it's still going
and it still has a niche in performing
large surveys of the sky even today and
what was the camera or instrument that
was bolted onto it for your use this was
Cersei this was the Cambridge infrared
survey instrument it was actually built
by the instrumentation group at The
Institute of astronomy in Cambridge
where I was it was literally being
constructed down the hall or at least in
the next building and a whole group of
us went out to La Palma together the
instrument went out ahead of us along
with some people to to set it up and
attach it to the telescope and then it
was sort of all hands on deck for this
first observing run to see how it worked
when we actually pointed it up at the
sky on the telescope the goal of my
project together with my supervisor was
to measure the masses of Galaxy clusters
so I still work on Galaxy clusters today
this is where it all started and the
whole point was to use a new instrument
to make observations in a new way to try
out a new technique
to get the masses of Galaxy clusters so
the technique was gravitational lensing
now we've talked about gravitational
lensing before oftentimes in the context
of these really spectacular images where
you see giant distorted arcs as light
passes through mass of objects and gets
bent and distorted can also be measured
in the weak field where you just measure
statistically these weak distortions but
that's not what we were doing the idea
here is that we were looking at a Galaxy
cluster and we were looking for the
absence of galaxies or a depletion of
galaxies around that cluster due to the
sort of distortion of space-time this is
called the depletion effect or the
magnification effect and it's different
from that Distortion that Shear effect I
mentioned earlier because that measures
sort of the change in the gravitational
field as you move across an image what
that's not sensitive to is if you have a
nice smooth sheet of mass the time this
was called the mass sheet degeneracy but
if you just use this sheer technique you
might not be getting the whole picture
it might be an additive effect and so
this other technique of counting
was sensitive to that and would break
that math sheet degeneracy now the
second important point was that we were
doing it in the infrared and this was
what was new about this instrument
Cersei it was a wide field camera so for
the first time it was using these new
detectors four of them that allowed us
to capture large region of sky at one
time and it was working in the near
infrared so redder than Optical
wavelengths and that had the advantages
specifically for this technique that
this depletion effect would be maximized
this comes down to two competing things
first of all
the mass of this galaxy cluster is
magnifying
objects behind it that's a fundamental
thing about gravitational lensing makes
it a really useful tool so we're seeing
more we should see more galaxies than we
expect because they're being magnified
and they're coming into view
but at the same time the space around it
is being stretched and magnetized so
you're you're you're spreading them out
you're diluting the number of galaxies
so there's these two things that are
countering each other bringing more
galaxies into view but spreading them
out further and so in the infrared we
expected the spreading to win so that
we'd get fewer galaxies seen behind the
cluster and so we use this camera we
chose Abel 2219 as our guinea pig and we
tried the experiment did things work out
the way you expected then no of course
things didn't work out the way we were
expected
um you know the the instrument had some
quirks the weather wasn't great I seem
to remember there was a dust storm
coming in from the Sahara you know of
course things didn't work
um so we went back again A year later we
applied for more time this is where
three years doesn't start to seem like a
very long time Brady when you're under
pressure and so really the data came out
the second year that we ended up using
the first year was incredibly important
in understanding the instrument getting
it working it was the second Year's data
that went into this paper essentially
after analysis we found
a tentative signal that as expected
there were fewer galaxies behind the
cluster so we did see the signal that we
expected we did model that to get the
mass of the cluster out which was the
ultimate aim and essentially we put a
marker down for this is how well this
technique does or does not work which
then feeds into the rest of the
community so that they can make
decisions about what research priorities
are there going forward and what was the
mass of the cluster so it had a velocity
dispersed and we modeled of 800
kilometers per second we didn't weigh
the cluster in kilograms because we
couldn't do that we had to infer a mass
from a model and the way we model this
is through a very simple physical model
of a very simple spherical nice cluster
that it almost certainly isn't and that
model had a single parameter which was
related to the mass it's called the
velocity dispersion that just explains
how fast the galaxies are moving around
each other or the Dark Matter particles
due to the gravity so the bigger the
cluster the more range and velocities
you'll see and so velocity to dispersion
of 800 kilometers per second
that's a pretty hefty cluster not the
most massive in the universe but a good
size massive cluster Professor I've
asked you to get this paper after all
these years when you read it does it
read just the same as all papers is this
sufficiently Pro former now that it just
reads like a normal paper or do you feel
a bit cringy and think oh I was so young
and naive then like what do you feel
when you look at this now oh I wouldn't
feel cringy I think it stands up but
that's that's because I didn't write it
on my own there are other names here my
PhD Supervisor was second contributed
absolutely to the writing of the paper
and you know that that's very stringent
quality control so it wouldn't even have
been submitted if it wasn't up to
scratch this is the nice finished
product right this is this is the end
result but this is you know this is
where it started that's the dirt yeah so
you know me I don't throw anything away
so I pulled out this file look we
haven't had stickers I don't know where
the stickers came from but this sort of
you know traces the the history of it so
it's code here there are notes there are
scribbled notes you know there's a first
image which is pretty ropey this is the
actual observing log you know used to be
done on paper this was in La Palma these
were The Observers that were there I was
one among a team of many and this is
what we would record so the time the
frame what we were doing and you can see
these are all very technical sort of
calibration observations so it's only
later on that we actually started
looking at astronomical objects Abel
1689 which is a cluster we didn't use
M13 which we've made videos on before
but yeah yeah in the comments you can
see that we were learning as we were
going along the information was wrong or
missing that we were we were having
problems with Focus or we were testing
the focus this was all about getting to
know how the instrument worked when it
was actually on the telescope this is
amazing to say it's great yeah so that
was one aspect of it and then I don't
even know what these these things are
emails and code and plots and notes so
this is the messy bits of research what
are those types these tapes well this is
how we brought our data home back in the
old days Brady I've got some tapes at
home don't you yeah yeah this actually
reflected that the data was so big that
at the time the computers I was using to
process it didn't have enough storage to
hold like a gigabyte of data so I had to
keep putting it on tapes just to store
it I'm gonna save the tape yep
wow I had a very generous scholarship
that brought me to Cambridge paid my
fees paid my living expenses but it
didn't pay any field work expenses so at
the time I wasn't sure how I was going
to fund my way to go on this observing
trip at all
um so I looked around for any funding
sources I could find that would support
PhD students and I can't even remember
why but someone suggested that I write
to the worshipful company of scientific
instrument makers so this is a a guild a
professional Guild here in the UK of
quite obviously scientific instrument
makers so I wrote to them and I said
please do you have any funding stream
that I could apply for I'd be happy to
submit an application give you a report
whatever whatever you need and so they
wrote back and I kept the letter because
I just love it so much they wrote back a
lovely letter accompanied by a check for
200 pounds which at the time went a long
way to getting me to where I needed to
go and I have always been struck by the
generosity
um the unexpected generosity reflected
here I did write to say thank you I did
update them as to where uh what happened
on the observing trip but I'll I'll
record my thanks once again officially
to the worshipful company of scientific
instrument makers for helping getting
getting my PhD started
hopefully I acknowledge them in the
paper as well so I was very grateful for
their support as a young astronomer what
was it like when you submitted this
paper you got told it was going to get
published like what does that feel like
uh Pride relief I had one brick in the
wall of my thesis accomplished you know
after after some uncertain years you
know I had learned a lot through the
whole journey about how it's a structure
a project
and appreciation for how much went into
making an instrument work from from
scratch
um
and just just how you know uncertain the
whole process is which is why we always
have to have multiple lines of research
going at any one time because we don't
know when the weather is going to you
know Scupper things on a particular
night or a volcano is going to stop us
accessing our telescope or an earthquake
or a global pandemic you know
being a scientist really is about being
adaptable and and being resilient and
being creative because things will
almost inevitably not go the way you
think they're going to go so Ray one of
the reasons I think it's really nice
that we're filming this right now is
there's a pleasing symmetry around this
long forgotten paper because I wrote
this when I was uh and excited new PhD
student anxiously awaiting the delivery
of a brand new wide field instrument on
the William Herschel telescope that was
going to give us new capabilities that
we hadn't had before
and here 25 years later I'm now a
professor and I have my own PhD students
who are anxiously and excitedly awaiting
the commissioning of a brand new wide
field instrument on the William Herschel
telescope that's going to give us
entirely new ways of pursuing our
science so this is a little bit of a hot
tip to the instrument Builders out there
because I'm a user of telescopes of
scientific instruments but so much
effort goes in before that by the
project scientists by the engineers by
the technical team The Observatory staff
and I've seen it I've seen even on this
instrument what goes on so we are weeks
away from first light on this new
instrument called weave weave is the
William Herschel enhanced velocity
Explorer
okay I'm missing an a you're missing it
yeah
it's on the screen that's what that's
what it stands for that's what it stands
for there there it is exactly
tell me about
abel2219 can you have a soft spot in
your heart for a massive cluster of
galaxies absolutely you know there are
patches of sky but I I feel quite
proprietary about and certainly this one
I'd recognize it if I saw a picture of
it and I'd say oh I know that one
all wavelengths and together that makes
a very whitish light it doesn't emit
light at exactly the same amount at each
wavelength but overall it covers the
whole Spectrum however when we have an
artificial source of light we're not
always going to get that full spectrum
wavelength coverage and here's a really
extreme case of that